[Music]
so
i'm sure you know who tommy sotomayor is
right oh yeah have you seen this clip oh
well i don't know if this is the clip i
saw on twitter
is the one with the the black girl
no the one with the jace oh i have that
too i don't know if we could play that
one he goes pretty hard this is not that
this is a clip where
everybody's i mean a lot of people are
now calling him uh nurse
or black marsh did you see him with this
hoe they tried to call him out for
trying to okay i love tommy sotomayor
i've always liked him well watch this
you're gonna love him more
uh this is on that fresh and fit podcast
which we made fun of
[ __ ] i actually got a question for
you
i'm really not trying to offend you
if you start off saying that
[Applause]
i hope that you really don't feel that
type of way i don't feel like that's
what i'm trying to tell her like i was
going to say that that was going to be
my closing
anybody that knows me knows i like a
conversation for the sake of the
conversation yeah at the end of the
conversation i'm like the i i was in
debate club when you get through with it
you shake hands when you get through
playing basketball you don't get mad
because you won or you lost it's a part
of the competition okay we are supposed
to tell that the [ __ ] lebron james
wouldn't meet the undertaker that went
all the way out there to meet him
he
here to entertain enlightening and
educate a little bit and so when i was
talking to her i was just trying and the
same with you or anybody else
i challenged them
yeah you should want to be challenged if
you're having a discussion why is it
that we can only talk to people who
agree with us
in fact that's what's making america can
i ask that question
that was the question
so i don't know if you seen i unfollowed
you oh oh [ __ ] that's gonna re-follow me
i will but only if it's
convenient for me to to follow you so
can you turn that [ __ ] off no they can
hear they can hear you go ahead okay so
i unfollowed you because every time i go
on my instagram i see you down playing
black women
as in
keep in mind she's basically a hooker
just so you guys know everybody all the
women there are are strippers and or
hookers oh is that the sh yeah fresh and
fit that's their stick okay to the point
where
i don't see no other race but you always
posting something about a black woman
did this or what they're doing and i'm
like [ __ ] you black yourself what are
you doing so i got tired of seeing it
and i want to just say the one that got
to me the one that made me unfollow you
was the one that
it was the one with the the lady that
had the wig or something like that and i
guess you know which one i'm talking
about i don't because i talk about the
ladies and wigs a lot so i was like
exactly
i like him a lot they're all black so
it's just like
it's just like so it's just like like i
was cool you know i was really cool
everything but
what what was that that bothered you
about that post it was um specifically
you were saying something about does it
drive you crazy emerge because this
drove me this is something probably
maybe only drove me crazy but
you know how much these microphones cost
do you see how many they have
look how many of these they have these
they have good ones and does it also not
bother you that they took a really nice
expensive five thousand dollars with the
microphone just there
and they took it and they put it on one
of those cheap amazon desk stands
well you gotta save money somehow um i
guess uh
she was playing you with something
somebody that reported your page i don't
really know i don't follow you about a
week ago so you're the one making the
point i feel like you should know right
oh this escalates
remember it was around my dad's death
but i didn't want to see it on my tl
because i'm like damn tl stands for
timeline
well okay
i explained it to people like this one i
don't understand why black women get to
tell a black man because you're black
you can't talk about the this group
well hold on
if you want me if you go to espn you're
gonna get sports you're not gonna get
politics you're gonna get sports so when
people come to me they're gonna hear me
talk about what i think is the problem i
think we have a lot of issues and i
think they are starting with the idea of
our women so i will speak on that now
you can go to another guy and hear him
tell young pharaoh tell you about how
black women are god and then cheat on
y'all and beat you you
okay well that's can you start seeing
why they're calling on black marsh it
gets better
go hear that if you want but i think
it's odd that you're willing to listen
to somebody tell you how great you are
and you kings and queens and how you're
the most beautiful thing on the earth
but you're not listening to somebody say
the other side the same thing i was
saying on the discussion why not hear
more than one side so you can go to
somebody else and hear them tell you all
the things that make you feel good but
if you come to me i'm going to tell you
the opposite because why do you need to
hear that and the last thing is i grew
up in a family most of us grew up around
black folks if you grew up with our
black mom a black grandma or a black
aunt it's funny how we listen to those
who talk who supposedly love us talk to
us and say sit your black ass down don't
do this
you can listen to your mama who had you
talk to that way but by the way the dude
is dying the dude did you see the oh
yeah yeah and he's like so the whole so
the two looks like this
the two hosts right now are like yeah we
have gold we're gonna shut up this is
gonna be great and it gets really good
because i don't know if you know that
well if anybody would know it would be
marsh but marsh
i don't know if you know this but black
women don't like being talked down to
by black white or any men really it's a
very uh it's a delicate dance yeah
you don't know who you could simply
unfollow that lets me know a lot of
people are soft i can follow someone and
i will argue not your black so you can't
talk about blacks i'll say does what you
say have merit i don't care if a white
person's talking about blacks because
here's what's funny you don't want a
black man to talk about black women but
if a white woman did it would you listen
to that no
you say she was racist if anybody else
did so who can talk about it so my
problem my more i ain't gonna say
problem
my
whole debate is
why only you only target black like i'm
pretty sure white
people get on youtube why you don't why
you don't but the black into me what's
the difference is that now we're now
we're now we're splitting hairs
uh um say something about them look when
i say come on now i know every race get
on your ass
when i say white women got flat i did a
whole song about white women today we
ain't talking about those songs we're
talking about your post
maybe when i say something about white
people they eat it yeah because it's
black they eat it
i can get up in the front of a comedy
set and i've done it several times made
fun of the white people in the audience
they
they eat it they're not sitting around
wearing their emotions on their
shoulders and white men don't go around
talk about some call me king
[Laughter]
he's great i've always loved him he's
always been i i found out about him
years ago when he was beefing with tariq
nasheed
and him and tariq nasheed had a long
standing beef
and the thing is is i love tommy
sotomayor mayor but i also love tariq
and sheed for different reasons and
they're way more similar than they are
different they just have different
opinions and they had a [ __ ]
batman and joker thing going for a long
time but this i love tommy this is what
it gets i mean obviously oh no yeah i
want to watch this no no i know i know
but i'm just saying what i'm about to do
here hey virgie are you in the thing
because i see he's in the thing because
he's posting pictures yes sir okay is
this her would you just post it is this
her yep that's her okay hold on hold
hold on
so question marsh
would you
no
and i know everybody's like boomers
no that is how they sell though yeah
that is exactly how they sound all right
um
but no that's not much okay she's a
little
i don't like the tats it's a little too
a little too hood she's pretty in the
face but bad tats and she's a little you
know not my type she's garbage she that
chick is garbage oh well hold on let's
look at her let's look at her butt
oh
no
yeah no not my
oh all right let's continue let's let's
let's because we have to finish out
black merch
only one group of people who keep giving
themselves false praise you want to get
mad that somebody's talking about
somebody wearing okay but we should have
every right to feel that we can and i
have every right to say whatever but
listen exactly
you should know our background no but
you should know our background i don't
she's not sh she's on drugs and
everybody i think she's on something
she's very like
[Music]
yes so exactly we should have every
right to feel guys
i speak on it because i know the
background so if you can go on your
stuff and talk about how great you are
and i don't go on there and tell you you
can't
why would you follow me see what i say
then come tell me what i can't say when
you said you can say what you want
that's true though i always say this
black women love to say how strong they
are
if you're really strong
other people's opinion shouldn't bother
you that much it don't bother you
but
we're six minutes in now
it seems to be bothering you you're six
minutes into an excellent
explanation about how much this bothered
you yeah this is the whole point of this
on you're the most black would you want
to talk about your own race but imagine
going on a show fresh and fit as
annoying as they are if you're huge or a
huge show right so imagine going on a
show to yell at somebody and say
publicly you unfollowed them like who
cares
listen see what you said
why would you want to dust it
they're all trash bags talk about your
own race but if i sit there and say how
great they were you wouldn't say
why would you want to talk about your
own race exactly all i can do is big
group of people i wouldn't so all i can
do is pick up a groupie is that a good
is that a new word in the big up a group
of people i don't like if i was
complimenting you i'd be like big up in
mike
oh i don't like the way that sounded no
no i don't mind i say that you got to go
to somebody else go to another dude who
talk and beat you up i won't because
it's not my job
you live in america but you can talk bad
about america they don't serve you
by the way he's just if you think we're
frustrated can you imagine how
frustrated he is but logically
completely missed the line
is that no one is above criticism
regardless of where the criticism comes
from it is if it's a valid critique
a fact is a fact that does not change
based on who's why do the hosts have
worse mics than the guests necessarily
they never argue what i say it's just
i'm black and i can't say it which is a
childish argument you can say a [ __ ]
can't talk about midgets because he's
[Laughter]
a fat small can't talk about fat girls
because she's fat that's a good
comparison it gets silly and like i said
when i brought up they're american they
were born in america but sit right here
and dissed the american government and
said all they do is lie so you can d but
you're american okay
and my point is
why every time i get on instagram you
the only person that's saying the same
thing about black women though because
nobody else is they're afraid to i mean
i don't know
why taking the same point yeah all like
over and over lady
like you're the only one like they
like people say what they say about
fresh affair but i don't see it every
day on them every time i go on my
instagram you're just
specifically only targeting but then if
you unfollowed him what does it matter
then black women and i didn't like that
because i'm like damn
instagram
is do it your way don't tell me not to
do it mine of course but i'm letting you
know
about it but i don't care you do it if
you obviously know how to build a house
better than me you build it don't tell
me to do it okay but i'm just letting
you know if i'm only found that i see it
this is my favorite episode of night
wave i think i've ever seen it it feels
very it's going off
because they kept calling you nurse it's
the brown kids that's
dude he's making the point that i mean
we've all had to make in this game for a
long time when people start going in
that circle but you do this and you say
this yeah okay so i don't like you okay
then unfollow me i mean yeah you keep
saying this thing and you get to a point
where you're like i don't care
like you're not watching
red letter media doing batman reviews
but then i'm not gonna follow you
because i think you're [ __ ] up okay
just and he's now he's getting report
okay
all right but i don't care
follow me i don't care i don't see
nothing else but black people
[Applause]
says the hooker
well it does if you do the [ __ ] you're
saying you do for money don't make
nobody
wow
that
that
was
a sledgehammer not even a sledgehammer
that was a
a an actual
train
coming down the tracks
and smashing her in the face
that was like getting hit
by a train
can i hear that again that was worse one
of the and it was he was so
lightning fast there you go talk about
care anybody else
i'm still rich so i don't care no i
don't follow money don't make nobody no
apparently it does if you do the [ __ ]
you're saying you do for money
in a room full of hookers
again that's a decapitation right like
that is that was the most you're done
you're done you're finished that was the
most violent
[ __ ] shutdown i've ever seen in the
years we've been doing this don't make
nobody that's not even the worst one
though it gets worse
you talked up jesus why wouldn't someone
listen to you when you say i understand
you don't like watching it don't watch
it that's why i don't like gay boys
you're getting
mad you're getting mad
i hate women that argue like this why
are you mad i'm mad because you're
[ __ ] annoying it's not
nothing to do with the point you made
you just won't shut up because you keep
talking about it like i was supposed to
give a [ __ ]
you sound insane no you sound insane
you're bothered by what i post i
all right all right let me let me just
mediate real fast i understand trust me
oh he's got the big boy stream deck
simply i understand i will i will tell
you this because i still follow him on
instagram uh he makes fun of everybody
oh no he don't he does you know
a couple of people yeah like so whether
he you know i mean he just saw the
i think some of these women are on drugs
dude don't i don't want to get sued you
don't want to get sued
i don't want to go you don't want it on
the bad side of big hooker
guess you can tag a picture of all of
them because on the episode it's got
their their instagrams listed yeah and
they're they're mostly normal
mostly
mostly
try to make an argument that he
disproportionately insults black women
more makes jokes on them more but he
makes fun of everyone um and you know i
kind of this is kind of
the issue like
if you don't like content just don't
watch it and that's it you know what i
mean and i unfollowed that's why okay
then why are we still talking about it
did you unfollow though watch it but i
just wanted to address them for it i'm
gonna be honest i didn't know he would
be here tonight i always wanted to
question him that he takes my i always
wanted to question him that
my phone
just to make sure that i'm good and i
respect that but i don't reply because i
simply don't respect him more because
he's just the fact that what he posts on
the ground and it's just like what you
texting me for and you do all this to
try to play black women like they just
just always ignorant or don't [ __ ]
ignorant what was that
a grenade agreement a grenade
it sounds like a jumbled word
a grenade
no and you know i don't know why it's
not like she made a mistake she says it
again later on same way no [ __ ] like you
can't do because he cares about it
listen if you care you wouldn't downplay
okay but if you care you wouldn't play
he's trying to benefiting your image
though can we just have this debate
please nobody else
who the [ __ ] are you though you know
what i mean
this woman
is such a loser but you're not listening
to me when i speak you're telling me
what i should be doing instead of asking
me why i do it i asked you why would i
accept it when i asked you why that was
my favorite even now what i'm saying
when i say i ask you why and when i
asked you why and when i and i asked you
and i asked you why
continue all right so simply put he
makes this content you might not like
how he disproportionately makes black
women but yeah you have the right to do
that i mean
yeah so it's just a little yeah like
it's like you're you're it's like if
you're if you don't like something just
don't watch it i don't that's why i
don't follow two weeks ago yeah i don't
know did it she unfollow
i want to see it but i didn't know he
would be here to ask him that question
today yeah
she wanted clarity all right all right
that's no she doesn't i think that she
wants to be able to control the person
because i don't want to convert
i wanted to know why a girl didn't want
to date me if she says it that's the
answer not to argue with this girl as
she states it
and now it gets personal well what you
should do no you shouldn't tell me funny
listen
because like he
you get an answer to a question you know
what i i i wouldn't why i know what it
is
you got an answer to a question you
asked why do i post what i post
this is the most recent
[ __ ] in the world he talked about so
many black people on his platform but
this [ __ ] was trying to [ __ ] a bad
[ __ ] like me like stop playing like
[ __ ]
well you wanted to [ __ ] me blew me to
him
she flew me to him now let me let me let
me ask a question
did you get on the plane
your friend and my
[Music]
he is so great
he is so great and i [ __ ] your friend
he is so great
and i [ __ ] your friend that's very
funny
maybe he didn't [ __ ] you because your
friend was hotter did you think about
that wow
and this now goes to the whole root of
why she doesn't like him well you merci
i i think you're being a little a
grenade right now so
i guess what's chat
so this
so this all ties back to him not [ __ ]
her [ __ ] [ __ ] friend when they
were out in the same town yeah
he [ __ ] their friends [ __ ] show me
zebras over here
i'm not acting stupid yes you are
told you that's how she says it it's the
truth
yet you flew to my house you said you
wanted
no i'm not a party party tell me what
[ __ ] [ __ ] on me shut up
she's a porta potty i should know
because you want people to know you are
wanting to let somebody know i try to
[ __ ] you this is
nobody
[Applause]
now the reason this thing is up is
because her titty came out
so they're covering her titty that came
out
this is somebody who was recording it
live
what a vibrant culture right
uh this i think virgin is the picture
we're talking about
all these hoes what an absolutely
vibrant culture i was gonna find uh
there it is an individual one but i i
bailed i'm sorry no no but this is the
one right
this looks like it
the bottom left in the red uh-huh she's
a comedian
right yeah
one in the bottom middle can get it stop
it none of them they're all trash bags
you don't like the middle one on the
bottom no we're not doing this
um points this is why you get in the
trouble you get into by the way